[Music]
i've used creative communication to
solve problems related to especially
people learning different science for
example in chemistry people sometimes
have a hard time understanding
subatomic particles and molecules and
atoms and making those connections
between quantities and numbers so
instead of jumping right into that which
can be very difficult for people i've
learned to be creative and use analogies
or relating that to something that is
more accessible such as cooking or money
or building something and then when
people can make the relation between
something large and familiar to
something small or subatomic and
unfamiliar it makes it easier for them
to make those connections and build upon
that knowledge so several years ago i
started making videos of myself
explaining biology and entomology in
language that was accessible and
familiar to people my age and people who
don't fit the stereotypical model of a
scientist
it's a choice that i'm really glad that
i made actually i've received so much
positive feedback about videos no more
complicated than me holding a bug in
front of a camera and
actually
just like this
me
literally
holding a bug in front of a camera and
explaining what makes it tick
note to self
i should make a video about what makes
ticks tick that'd be pretty cool wait
sorry there's nothing here nor there um
the
point of what i'm saying is the choice
not to excise my personality the choice
to bring all of my quirkiness into how i
communicate is what seems to make the
difference a big part of being creative
really can be just figuring out how to
bring all of you to whatever it is that
you choose to do
[Music]